So, it works to divide both sides in an inequality by the same number to get a
solution, or does it? What happens if we have negative x is greater than or
equal to 4? Well, using the method we used before, we would divide both sides by
negative 1. And we'd find that x is greater than or equal to negative 4. If this
is right, then that means that this inequality up here, the original one we had,
is satisfied by any value of x that is greater than or equal to negative 4. Now,
last time I went through and I did a sort of sanity check, where I plugged in
some test values that fit the solution interval we've come up with. And I
plugged them in to the original equation to make sure that my answer made sense.
Now, can you do the sanity check yourself this time, and tell me if this
solution right here is correct? Just tell me, yes or no.